so you're saying that there should be an
effort for increased vaccinations
of of kids going to school just not for
societal benefit but for the benefit of
each individual kid right so right now
kids under
12 right or not yet vaccinated is that
correct yeah i think so
and it's going to be it's not going to
be in time for school opening that they
get vaccinated
um
and then
i mean i suppose the teachers are all
going to be vaccinated it makes sense
for them to do that but i'm just worried
the kids are going to be transmitting it
amongst them and many states don't allow
mass mandate in school so
i think that's what's driving the larger
narrative
in the u.s to protect kids
it's kind of what i hear from daniel
griffin
because increasing numbers of kids are
being admitted to hospitals now because
they're the mid they're becoming the
major unvaccinated population they're
hanging out over the summer and that's
just going to get worse in the fall
and so you could have a lot of kids with
long covered and disabled their entire
lives right so
and of course
hearing from people who are vaccine
hesitant i hear exactly the kids
statement but they're saying
they don't want the long
vaccine
the long-term effects of the vaccine to
affect the kids that's the
of the co of this new vegetable which i
would say is
as as i said before you can't say
never but
we do know that long
covid exists
we don't know for how long because we've
only looked out six or eight months we
know that exists
and the frequency is increasing it
certainly exists in young kids and we
have no idea about long vaccine effects
so i think they have to make their
decision
based on that
but yeah
but your question is why don't we just
open up
society say here we have these vaccines
if you want to protect yourself i think
it's mainly the school that's driving
the whole narrative that's my opinion in
which direction not to open up or no to
open up but to try and get
you know their efforts at the federal
level to get people vaccinated right but
see uh how high are the risk for kids i
mean as my understanding was it's i mean
yes it's non-zero but it's very low
for
but what is the numbers now 70 000
hospitalizations so far in kids as of
last week
so yes it's low but
i i that polio was low polio was 20 30
000 kids a year paralyzed and
well many people have actually argued
that that vaccine wasn't necessary you
know
that wasn't a substantial enough problem
but paralyzed is different than hospital
so what what does hospitalized mean
but this is the long covered question i
mean this is the open question it was
long covered in kids what is that so
well
a lot of the same issues cognitive
issues
motor issues
respiratory
gi dysfunction how long
we don't know
i mean it could end in a year
as you know there are other post
acute infectious sequelae that we know
about you know chronic fatigue mecfs
is thought to be a post-infectious
sequelae which has gone for many decades
now and many millions of people this
could be another another one of those so
i'm just saying it might be worth airing
on the side of
not letting the kids get infected yeah
but well
i'm trying to keep an open mind here and
i appreciate you doing you're doing the
same of course i
uh lean on
definitely not requiring people to get
vaccinated but i do think
getting vaccinated is just
the wiser choice looking uh
all the different trajectories before us
getting vaccinated is um
seems like
from the data it seems like the obvious
choice frankly but i'm also trying to
keep an open mind because some things in
the past that seemed obvious would turn
out to be completely wrong
so i'm trying to keep an open mind here
you